"Дизельгейт" у Німеччині сягнув нового апогею
Наприкінці минулого тижня суд у Штутгарті
виніс рішення на користь заборони дизельних автівок у місті
І вже цієї середи уряд ФРН, профільні організації
і 5 найбільших німецьких автовиробників
зберуться на так званий "дизельний саміт"
щоб обговорити майбутнє дизельних двигунів
Оглядачі називають це останнім шансом автоконцернів пояснити
як вони збираються привести до норми рівень шкідливих викидів
спричинених дизельними автівками
Головним аргументом ворогів дизеля
є величезна екологічна шкода
якої ці автівки завдають довкіллю
Щонайменше у 80 німецьких містах
рівень допустимого вмісту шкідливих вихлопів
у повітрі хронічно перевищується
На німецьких дорогах дуже багато дизельних автівок
Загалом свідомі в плані захисту довкілля
німці охоче купували дизель
бо, по-перше, завдяки субсидіям держави
ціни на дизельне пальне нижчі, ніж на бензин
а по-друге, німці були переконані
що куплені ними дизельні автівки німецького виробництва
відповідають екологічним приписам
Аж поки не спалахнув "дизельний скандал"
довкола "Фольксвагена" і не зясувалося
що не лише він, а й інші німецькі автовиробники
маніпулювали даними про шкідливі викиди
Утім, багато хто вважає заборону дизеля
у Німеччині вельми проблематичною
Прихильники дизеля стверджують, що програми
які регулюють систему вихлопних газів
можна модернізувати таким чином
що шкідливі викиди скоротяться від 25 до 50 відсотків
Інші вважають, що це дасть поліпшення
лише на 9 відсотків
Утім, технічно це складна процедура і незрозуміло,
хто за це має платити
Якщо автоконцерни, що було б логічно
то це може суттєво підкосити німецький автопром
флагман економіки ФРН
А криза автопрому може потягти за собою
й кризу цілої німецької еколоміки
Крім того, за даними міністерсва еконлогії ФРН
цього все одно буде недостатньо
аби Німеччина виконала кліматичні цілі
До того ж, власники дизельних автівок
масово можуть зажадати через суди
відшкодувань через заборону дизеля
Усього цього уряд Німеччини хоче уникнути
Та який вихід?
Відповіді шукатимуть у середу в Берліні